il
nous sommes le lundi 9 février bonsoir
et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle édition
du journal de la rédaction est dans
l'actualité locale
aujourd'hui top départ des dépôts de
candidatures aux élections
départementales de mars huit jours pour
déposer sa liste en préfecture les
derniers noms les dernières réactions à
suivre et notamment celle de michel
laugier le président de la communauté
d'agglomération de saint quentin qui va
se présenter à montigny la communauté
d'agglomération de saint-quentin
justement qui propose une nouvelle
semaine de l'emploi un forum des
formations métiers vient de se tenir
dans ce cadre et puis maltraitance
utilisation abusive de la chambre
d'isolement dans de nombreux services
psychiatriques c'est ce que dénonce dans
le département une association à la
commission des citoyens pour les droits
de l'homme vient d'organiser cinq
mobilisation simultanément ce week end
en plateau tout à l'heure sa présidente
mylène escudier
nous allons donc débuté cette semaine
par de la politique les élections
départementales se déroule à la fin du
mois de mars mais c'est dès aujourd'hui
que les candidats leur binôme est les
binômes et les suppléants doivent
déposer leurs listes l'occasion de faire
le point notamment sur le canton de
montigny le bretonneux qui comporte
également la commune de guyancourt sur
le canton de montigny le bretonneux fin
du suspense c'est bien le maire de
montigny michèle losier président de
l'agglomération qui portera les couleurs
de la droite
rassemblés sous la bannière épi ensemble
pour les yvelines dans cette élection me
paraît important que le maire de
montigny et président de lacaune et
aigle opération que je suis soit présent
dans ce combat puisque dans les années à
venir
le travail qui devra être fait entre la
commune de l'intercommunalité et le
conseil général sera de plus en plus
important les valeurs sont toujours les
mêmes moi c'est essayer de d'avoir les
meilleurs résultats dans ma
collaboration avec le
conseil général aujourd'hui conseil
départemental demain sur les compétences
qui sont les siennes notamment pour tout
ce qui touche à l'action sociale pour
tout ce qui touche au collège aux routes
départementales
un canton observés à la loupe il est
actuellement détenu par le maire de
guyancourt françois de ligne et pour ces
élections le socialiste a constitué un
binôme avec 100 migrants gang
la première fédérale des yvelines et lui
attrape mais qui a été pendant plusieurs
années conseillère municipale
d'opposition à montigny la gauche
apparaît divisée pour ces élections
europe ecologie les verts et le front de
gauche ayant décidé de présenter une
candidature à partir de ce territoire
que je souhaite défendre des valeurs
mais qui ont une résonance aussi
nationale ça va être des valeurs
sociales lutter contre les politiques
aujourd'hui d'austérité défendre en fait
véritablement la démocratie locale qui
est attaqué de différentes manières de
façon institutionnelle avec la réforme
des collectivités territoriales défendre
véritablement une politique sociale
puisque aujourd'hui ce seront
essentiellement les domaines sur lequel
le département va intervenir et ses
politiques sociales elles sont sont
finalement mises en péril par une
politique d'austérité
faire de la politique un peu
différemment donc on a une équipe qui
est très très jeune on a une équipe de
gens qui ne sont pas déjà mère qui ne
sont pas déjà vice président de la
communauté d'agglo donc vraiment un
renouveau de la politique pour bien
montrer que tous les citoyennes tous les
citoyens peuvent s'emparer de la
politique le front de gauche et europe
écologie les verts vont organiser des
ateliers de réflexion les 5 et 6 mars
afin de mobiliser le plus d'électeurs
autre binôme à se présenter cette fois
pour le front national et jenny lavigne
et sylvain grisons élus et de montigny
ancien militaire la sécurité et son
principal thème de campagne
la sécurité et je dirais
une certaine évolution de la physionomie
locale qui
énormément changé depuis 25 ans puisque
j'habite montigny-le-bretonneux depuis
1990 est gelée considérablement vu
changer et pas uniquement montini bien
évidemment nous irons sur le terrain
nous irons tracter boîte est également
et tenir certainement des réunions
publiques lors des dernières élections
du canton en 2008 françois de ligne et
l'avait emporté dès le premier tour avec
plus de 70% des voix
son principal adversaire déjà michel
laugier et un candidat divers gauche
michel thomas sur le canton de maurepas
à présent les verts et le parti
communiste qui ne rejoignent pas le
parti socialiste pour les
départementales ils viennent de
présenter un front commun une alliance
qui se présente comme un mouvement
solidaire en faveur de l'écologie
la lutte contre les inégalités titulaire
brigitte boucher candidate europe
écologie et conseillère municipale de
magny les hameaux et alain février
militants parti communiste front de
gauche est une association avec le ps à
mon avis serait contre nature
aujourd'hui étant donné que la politique
nationale n'a absolument pas une
politique
ni écologique ni sociale ni solidaire et
ni démocratique puisque toutes les lois
qui sont mises en route maintenant seul
le son à l'insu je dirais destitué des
citoyens alors qu'on souhaite
derrière ces élections pouvoir
construire dans les cantons dans les
villes de notre canton
j'irai de l'essayer de de construire des
rassemblements citoyens à partir
jared nos sensibilités politiques
différentes mais ouverte à tout le monde
et c'est à dire d'une autre façon dire
de repartir du local pour reconstruire
quelque chose pour que les gens se
réapproprient la politique et qu'ils
aillent une haute vision du politique et
dans ce canton toujours d'autres binômes
sont déjà constitués ils vendent val
conseiller général sortant du canton de
chevreuse et alexandra rosetti pour
l'ump udi et ismaila vannes conseiller
général du canton ne mord pas christine
mercier qui fait campagne avec lui pour
le parti socialiste les candidats de la
gauche sont en revanche rassemblés sur
le canton de trappes avec notamment les
communes les communes des longs cours de
la verrière les listes était présenté ce
midi elle sera portée par alain ajaj
maire communiste de la verrière et
jeanine marie la première adjointe et
divers gauche de trappes et les
conseillers conseillère générale
sortante sur ce compte
alors ce rassemblement ce volant d'une
volonté d'avoir un maximum de deux
représentants de la gauche après avec un
parti une étiquette partie sans
étiquette parties s'étaient pas c'était
pas là l'essentiel
l'essentiel c'était la reconnaissance
des qualités de chacun pour pouvoir
porter cette cette fibre sociale auprès
auprès des gens un département qui a
suffisamment de richesses pour qu'ils
s'interrogent sur la répartition de ces
richesses et qu' une partie de ses
richesses ce puisse être destinée au
développement et à la réponse aux
besoins qui se sont à des besoins
sociaux éducatifs ou d'aménagements ou
des besoins écologiques sur notre notre
canton voilà pour les derniers noms
concernant cette campagne départementale
qui est des buts c'est les élections qui
mobilise en général assez peu les
électeurs nous avons voulu savoir si
vous connaissiez tout simplement le nom
de vos élus locaux les élus qui siègent
au conseil général voici les réponses
avec ce micro trottoir c'est notre
question du jour
je connais pas je ne vous intéresse pas
on reçoit tellement de trucs j'ai le jeu
je peux je connais pas le nom bas mais
non il n'ya pas me sortir non j'ai pas
le lot son nom je connais pas non non
non la politique sert joue pas mon truc
un matin où la surmonter je connais le
maire et bien sûr des adjoints mais
l'incendié général sur le canton qui
fait monter lui en cours voilà tu
connais je connais pas non même pas vous
avez des voisins
le conseiller général je crois que ces
messieurs veulent normal non tout à fait
du travail un tout de même pour les élus
avec cette campagne qui débute politique
toujours mais avec le décès de françois
neveux c'est le maire honoraire
d'elancourt il a tenu la ville de 1969 à
1971 il a aussi été conseiller municipal
entre 65 et 70 7 puis de 83 à 96 il
avait vrai pour la création de saint
quentin en yvelines c'est une leucémie
foudroyante qu'il l'a emporté âgé de 82
ans il venait de gérer les affaires
courantes de la ville de louveciennes
dans le cadre d'une délégation spéciale
lucian où les élections avaient été
annulés santé polémique également les
membres de la commission des citoyens
pour les droits de l'homme se sont
rendus devant différents centre
hospitalier des yvelines samedi dernier
pour manifester contre les mauvais
traitements en psychiatrie et les
données révélées par la commission
départementale des soins psychiatriques
sont jugés inquiétants par l'association
qui dénonce les pratiques des médecins
direction plaisir devant le centre
hospitalier jean-martin-charcot avec
williams elle et on en parle plus en
détails juste après avec notre invité en
plateau dénoncer les abus psychiatriques
voilà l'action qu'a mené samedi la
commission des citoyens pour les droits
de l'homme en manifestant devant
plusieurs centre hospitalier des
yvelines dans le viseur de l'association
les mauvais traitements infligés aux
malades
ou encore des procédures d'internement à
la demande d'un tiers appliquées de
manière abusive
vous avez plus de 85% des procédures qui
sont utilisés de cette façon pour nous
c'est inacceptable parce que ce sont des
milliers de personnes qui sont
hospitalisées dans le département des
yvelines avec beaucoup moins de garantie
pour le patient parce que vous avez qu
un seul certificat médical qui est
nécessaire au lieu de deux et vous avez
l'accord de la famille qui n'est pas
obligatoire et même la famille peut être
en désaccord avec la procédure
d'hospitalisation sous contrainte et les
psychiatres on râle dernier groupe
procéder à l'internement la personne
l'association dénonce l'excès de pouvoir
des psychiatres mais aussi le manque de
contrôles de la part des autorités
depuis 2006 notamment un plaisir vous
avez aucune visite ni du préfèrent ni du
président du tribunal de grande instance
or ces autorités doivent visiter
l'hôpital au moins une fois par an pour
l'association les soins administrés aux
balades sont également considérée comme
inadaptée cv quand quelqu'un se fut
hospitalisé sous contrainte c'est quand
même sont des traitements très lourds
qui selon lui sont administrés avec des
effets secondaires dévastateurs avec une
dépendance très forte et vous avez aussi
des mauvais traitements vous avez aussi
les électrochocs car la sismothérapie
j'ai une belle soeur qui vient d'être
interné en hôpital psychiatrique
on la met sous psychotropes elle est
devenue un vrai légumes alors que
évidemment elle avait des problèmes
psychologiques c'est un fait mais les
médicaments qu'on lui donne ne l'êtes
pas bien au contraire
bien au contraire elle est encore plus
dépressifs qu'elle ne l'était avant des
appels à témoins ont été lancées avec
une distribution de tracts pour
recueillir des témoignages mais aussi
redonner de la valeur à la parole des
malades invitait donc mylène escudier
bonsoir ça vous êtes la présidente de
cette association la commission des
citoyens pour les droits de l'homme on
vient de voir les images de l'une de vos
actions de ce week end il y en a eu
devant cinq établissements au total les
mots employés sont assez dures on les a
entendus psychiatrie barbarie
électrochoc ça suffit quelle est la
situation dans les grandes lignes
actuellement on est vraiment dans une
dans une barbarie aujourd'hui avec elle
celle de la telle manière que la
psychiatre il exerce alors il faut
savoir que nous en tant qu'association
droits de l'homme dénonçant les
violations des droits de l'homme en
psychiatrie donc c'est vrai qu'on
utilise des mots forts et c'est vrai que
la psychiatrie c'est un domaine on ne
parle pas assez
il ya beaucoup d'abus et il faut savoir
qu'en france on est un des pays les plus
respectueux en matière de droits de
l'homme dans le milieu psychiatrique
parce que et plusieurs rapports le
dénonce d'ailleurs notamment le rapport
du contrôleur général des lieux de
privation de liberté qu'il énonce les
conditions désastreuses d'internement
avec des patients qui sont attachées ou
en contention pendant des jours enfermés
dans des chambres d'isolement sous
traitement psychiatrique
donc nous si vous voulez en tant
qu'association dénonce les internements
abusifs c'est pour ça qu'on a manifesté
devant cinq établissements
psychiatriques ce samedi dans les
yvelines parce que la situation est
particulièrement inquiétante dans le
département avec un non respect des
procédures d'hospitalisation et ya un
manque de contrôle de la part des
autorités
sur quoi vous basez pour l'affirmer
alors on a demandé en fait auprès de
chaque direction des hôpitaux
accueillant des personnes hospitalisées
sous contraintes du département leurs
statistiques au fait on copie du
registre où sont notifiés toutes les
dates des visites des autorités ce qu'il
faut savoir que selon la loi vous avez
le procureur le préfet et le président
tribunal de grande instance qui doivent
effectuer des visites de contrôle
justement pour veiller à ce que les
droits des patients soient respectés est
ce que la dignité de ces derniers soient
aussi respecter ce qu'il n'y ait pas
d'abus
et c'est pour la loi n'est pas respectée
aujourd'hui la loi n'est absolument pas
respectée parce qu'il ya pour tous les
hôpitaux psychiatriques mis le président
du tribunal de grande instance
ni le préfet n'ont effectué deux visites
depuis 2006 donc ça fait plus de sept
ans maintenant dans huit ans la
situation est inacceptable d'autant plus
qu'on a manifesté donc ça me dit on a eu
de nombreux témoignages de parents
notamment de perdre
d'enfants qui se trouve actuellement
internés et dans des conditions
désastreuses avec des conditions de
traitement inhumaines parce que les
personnes sont complètement drogué c'est
le témoignage des parents qu'on a reçues
qu'on a rencontrés lors de
manifestations samedi
quel recours pour ses parents justement
parce que enfin déjà quel est le
processus aussi parce que les enfants se
retrouve interné mais il a bien fallu
qui est un élément déclencheur donc déjà
commencé à s'opère finalement que les
gens comprennent bien
aujourd'hui déjà comment ça se passe
pour qu'un internement alors vous avez
plusieurs types d'hospitalisation vous
avez l'hospitalisation à la demande d'un
tiers qui comme son nom l'indiqué est à
la demande d'un tiers donc le tiers
étant le proche ou un membre de la
famille et vous avez besoin de deux
certificats médicaux dont un qui émane
d'un médecin extérieur à l'établissement
d'accueil et vous avez besoin la
personne dans un état mental ou qui
nécessitent normalement des soins donc
sa cellule la procédure à la demande
d'un tiers normal si je puis dire
ensuite vous avez la procédure à la
demande d'un tiers en urgence qui comme
son nom l indique c en cas d'extrême
urgence
et là il faut qu'un seul certificat
médical au lieu de deux dans le cadre de
la procédure normale et aussi la demande
d'un membre de la famille ou d'un proche
et enfin vous avez une dernière
procédure qui est l'hospitalisation à la
demande d'un tiers en cas de péril
imminent
donc là c'est en cas de péril imminent
ou là et là que l'accord de la famille
n'ait pas demandé n'est pas obligatoire
et si vous voulez donc ce sont les trois
procédures majoritaire et vous avez
aussi dans le cadre d'un trouble à
l'ordre public sur arrêté préfectoral
une personne qui ce qui peut se
retrouver hospitalisé sous contrainte il
faut savoir particulièrement dans le
département des yvelines
vous avez un taux d'utilisation des
procédures dites d'urgence ou péril
imminent qui est excessif parce que vous
avez plus de 85%
si les proches l'utilisent c'est qu'il
ya véritablement danger et que les
familles sont démunis alors yahia les
deux car près ce que vous savez on a des
témoignages de
deux personnes qui sont actuellement
internés ou qu'on a réussi à aider avec
par le biais d'un avocat et c'est avec
l'aide d'avocats pour les faire sortir
d'internement abusif parce que vous avez
des histoires d'héritage aussi ou de
divorce et des personnes qui sont en
pleine procédure de divorce et pour
obtenir la garde des enfants interne son
mari ou son sa future ex femme pour
avoir l'étiquette malades psychiatriques
et c'est sûr que là avoir gain de cause
pour obtenir la garde des enfants
parce que quand on a un étiqueté malades
psychiatriques on a beaucoup moins de
droits qu'un citoyen normal qu'elles
recourent derrière justement pour pour
les malades déjà qu'ils sont qui sont
internés parce que après vonau dit il
sont drogués donc ils ont plus vraiment
pleinement connaissance et capacité à
s'exprimer mais même pour les familles
pour les faire sortir quel recours sont
possibles
alors ils ont beaucoup de droits mais la
plupart du temps on les informe pas de
leurs droits et de leur voies de recours
donc c'est pour ça qu'on est là en tant
qu'association droits de l'homme pour
les informer pour les aider mais il faut
savoir que déjà quand une personne se
fait hospitaliser sous contrainte
elle a le droit de choisir un médecin
son choix pour pour avoir un avis
extérieur la situation au traitement
qu'on lui administre elle a droit a
demandé à avoir une personne de
confiance donc il peut être un membre de
sa famille ou un proche qui aura accès
au dossier médical etc et pourra
contrôler
d'un point de vue extérieur les
prescriptions qui lui sont administrés
droit vous a le droit aussi à un avocat
il faut savoir dans un délai de 12 jours
et ça c'est la loi c'est obligatoire
obligatoirement passer devant le juge
des libertés et de la détention
justement juge qui va décider si
l'hospitalisation est abusive ou pas
c'est difficile pour les familles aussi
de faire sortir les patients leurs
proches qui sont qu'il soit interné
c'est difficile ont en tout cas c'est
très clair que c'est facile je peux vous
assurer que la loi française le permet
c'est très facile d'internés quelqu'un
en psychiatrie en france on a plus de 73
mais l'hospitalisation sous contrainte
en france soit 3,4 fois plus qu'en
italie en espagne ou même en allemagne
donc il ya vraiment une situation
pourquoi on un terme plus en france est
ce qu'on est plus fou dans d'autres pays
je ne pense pas mais il ya une pareille
une surmédicalisation on prend
énormément de psychotropes et en tant
qu'association on tire la sonnette
d'alarmé aussi sur ces traitements qui
souffrent parce que la partie soit aussi
la question de l'internement qui vous
interpellent et sur lesquels vous vous
mobilisez mais la question des soins
aussi les sons sont à la limite sont
trop forts sont excessifs
rien que samedi on a manifesté devant
cinq établissements et je peux vous
assurer que dans devant les cinq
établissements voyez des légumes des
personnes qui quitteront plus dignité ça
c'est sûr et qui sont complètement
shooté c'est le mot et pour nous c'est
inacceptable parce que quand une
personne se retrouve hospitalisé
peut-être car oui à un moment donné elle
avait besoin de soutien besoin d'être
dans un moment bas de sa vie ou un coup
de blues ça peut arriver à tout le monde
mais personne ne mérite de tels
traitements
on a même des témoignages ou deux
d'anciens prisonniers ou de personnes
qui ont fait la prison et l'hôpital
psychiatrique qui préfère nettement la
prison parce qu'ils sont pas attachés
sur des lits
ils ont des choses à faire dans la
journée ils ont des activités donc non
on demande plus d'humanité dans les
hôpitaux
beaucoup moins de traitements
psychiatriques pour shooter les patients
allaient faire taire et puis avoir des
hôpitaux en total silence et puis aucune
humanité donc vraiment c'est ce qu'on
sait ce qu'on demande en tant
qu'association parce que les retours
justement par rapport à cette
mobilisation et quelle suite vous allez
donner à ce mouvement parce que vous
dites
les pouvoirs publics sont en la loi et
ne vérifient pas ce qui se passe
j'imagine que vous les appelez
directement
oui alors je précise quand même que le
procureur de la république est la seule
autorité du département a effectué les
visites de contrôle
donc c'est très bien après on a demandé
et on insiste auprès de l' agence
régionale de santé est ce qu'une enquête
soit lancée plus rapidement possible
pour justement trouver les véritables
raisons l'utilisation c'est procédure
dite d'urgence parce que je parlais du
fait que c'était très facile
d'hospitaliser quelqu'un est difficile
parfois de le faire sortir
mais faut savoir quand même que la
procédure en cas de péril imminent qui
quand même utilisé majoritairement dans
le département il ya ainsi juste un seul
psychiatre peut décider de l'avenir de
la personne sans même l'accord de la
famille c'est à dire que si la famille
est en désaccord
elle n'a pas son mot à dire et le
psychiatre aura le dernier mot vous
voyez ça donne beaucoup de pouvoirs pour
pour hospitaliser quelqu'un et pour la
priver de ses libertés les plus
fondamentales la suite du mouvement
donc la suite nous avons bien sûr en
tout cas on a eu de très bons retours
lors des manifestations on a rencontré
même le père du personnel soignant et
des victimes aussi les parents qui ont
besoin d'être pour pour dénoncer ce qui
se passe dans les hôpitaux
donc on va continuer on va continuer à
se mobiliser on va manifester et on va
prendre rendez vous avec les autorités
du département pour accélérer le
processus et les inciter à effectuer ces
contrôles qui sont vraiment nécessaires
juste une dernière question tout à
l'heure au début de l'entretien vous
disiez dans les yvelines
particulièrement il ya beaucoup de cas
sur les questions de l'internement c'est
plus excessifs que dans le reste de la
france
aujourd'hui c'est plus difficile dans
les yvelines que dans l'est de la france
véritablement parce qu'il a beaucoup de
coeur à vous nous l'avez dit à travers
toute la france mais les yvelines le
département des yvelines particulier sur
ce point la mer en tout cas nous reçoit
beaucoup de témoignages en tout cas de
personnes qui ont été hospitalisées à
charcot à versailles au chesnay à poissy
enfin on a vraiment beaucoup de cas donc
c'est vrai qu'il ya une situation dans
le département
rien qu'en matière d'internement en
interne beaucoup plus on est à plus de 2
les chiffres je les ai on est à
exactement 1147 hospitalisations pour
l'année 2013 je dis bien
hospitalisations sous contrainte
c'est énorme c'est vrai qu'on est en en
ile de france c'est clair mais c'est
proportionnellement parlant c'est un des
départements qui interne le plus donc il
ya besoin de contrôler et besoin de
réformes dans le domaine de la santé 506
fait aujourd'hui avec cette association
commission des citoyens pour les droits
de l'homme merci mylan escudier d'être
venu sur le plateau aux suites à cette
mobilisation de ce week end
éducation à présent et le combat d'une
ville à la verrière un nouveau
rassemblement vient de se tenir samedi
matin à l'appel de la municipalité avec
les familles il dénonce ensemble la
sortie du collège intercommunale
philippe de champaigne et par conséquent
des écoles élémentaires et maternelles
de la verrière du réseau d'éducation
prioritaire à la rentrée 2015 leur ep
augmentation des effectifs chutent des
subventions font partie des inquiétudes
il ya eu des avancées comme quoi
effectivement se mobiliser serre est
utile ça reste quand même une bonne
réponse de ce point de vue là mais il ya
encore un bout de chemin à faire et on
espère bien
que ce sera conclusif jeudi prochain
elle s'est avancée c'est la garantie
d'avoir des effectifs de même niveau
qu'en l'éducation prioritaire
ça c'était un axe majeur et mais je
trouve qu'il ya dans l'écriture de la
convention qu'ils ont proposé des
phrases qui peuvent paraître quelquefois
contradictoires un engagement sur la
durée dont nous avons besoin aussi pour
rassurer les enseignants rassurer les
parents la 19e semaine de l'emploi a
commencé vendredi ce week end premier
événement le forum des formations aux
métiers cette aiguille en cours tous les
élèves à partir du niveau de la 3e
étaient conviés le but de ce forum
différent d'un salon de l'étudiant faire
découvrir les formations
professionnelles très concrète et qui
mène très rapidement sur le marché de
l'emploi florane parfait david
charpentier pour les images dans le
pavillon waldeck-rousseau les haies les
fourmis de jeunes étudiants le forum des
formations aux métiers s'adresse
principalement aux élèves de troisième
ils sont là pour se renseigner sur ces
formations qui débouchent rapidement sur
le marché du travail
parfois sans idée très précise de ce
qu'il souhaite faire je pense qu'on a
encore le temps moins un ou deux ans
avant de prendre une décision
c'est important
reste à répandre son nez sur jonah de
son effort dans traitement des matières
en fait beaucoup sont venus ici
accompagnés de leurs parents des parents
qui se pose aussi beaucoup de questions
sur le choix difficiles de l'orientation
c'est beaucoup de choses à gérer en même
temps parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
questions qui se posent et
d'incertitudes
déjà nous il faut qu'on se mettre un
petit peu à niveau par rapport quelles
sont les formations qui existent
aujourd'hui
on a fait notre formation mais on ignore
complètement tout ce qui est possible et
donc il faut déjà voir dans sa région et
dans les yvelines toutes les formations
qui sont proposés pourtant dans ce forum
on parle de choses concrètes les
formations sont courtes professionnel
est porteuse d'emplois neuf secteurs
sont représentés parmi lesquels la
défense le commerce les transports ou
encore la santé des domaines dont on
parle beaucoup contrairement aux
établissements présents s'ils forment à
ces métiers ils sont moins connus que
les formations classiques et manque de
visibilité
la plupart des jeunes ne connaissent pas
forcément tous les métiers dans certains
secteurs d'activité comme le nôtre ils
vont connaître les métiers traditionnels
cibles telles que le maçon ou le
plombier mais en fait en réalité dans le
domaine du bâtiment il ya une multitude
de métiers qui se croisent et il ya
beaucoup de métier qu'ils ne connaissent
pas donc il faut juste leur y faire
penser c'est possible et les formations
existent ce genre de salon permet aussi
de valoriser cette filière qui est
souvent qui peut être connue des jeunes
est appréciée mais c'est un travail
aussi avec les parents à faire qui
souvent peuvent avoir une image négative
de cette filière là il voit la vie
filière générale ils se rendent pas
compte que parfois un jeune peut tout à
fait avoir de très belles perspectives
professionnelles en passant par cette
voie là la 19e semaine de l'emploi
continue demain c'est un forum de
recrutement qui aura lieu dans la
matinée au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
enfin fin de ce journal rendez vous
demain aux mêmes horaires pour un
nouveau point complet sur l'actualité
locale très belle soirée sur tv fil 78
ce sera avec le 7-8 sport sur notre
antenne
et